this year's nobel prize in physics is
about our entire universe the royal
swedish academy of sciences has decided
to aboard the 2011 nobel prize in
physics with one-half to Professor Saul
Perlmutter the supernova cosmology
project lawrence berkeley national
laboratory and university of california
berkeley USA and the other half jointly
to Professor Brian Schmidt the hiset
supernova search team australian
national university western creek
australia and professor adam riess the
high Zeb supernova search team John
Hopkins University and Space Telescope
Science Institute Baltimore resolved and
the Academy citation runs for the
discovery of the accelerating expansion
of the universe through observations of
distant supernovae
you